hello everyone
and welcome to this free webinar or rna
sequencing
for infectious diseases today's session
will
introduce you to rnac data analysis and
the upcoming online training program on
rnac data analysis visualization
and biological interpretation
my name is beepsha biswas and i am the
omixlogic community manager
responsible for daily interaction with
thousands of users
who are part of our bioinformatics
community managed by
pybiotic so now let me start by
introducing
the upcoming training program as well as
the team
in today's webinar we will review recent
publications and data sets
that demonstrate approaches to
differential
gene expression analysis pathway mapping
and
single cell clustering to study
inflammation response to infection
this transcriptomics program is the
third phase
of a six-month program on bioinformatics
for
infectious diseases that started
in january 2021. the first part of the
program focused
on infectious diseases and the use of
bioinformatics and big data for
infectious disease research diagnostics
as well as drug
and vaccine development
one of the major focus of this program
is to support ongoing research projects
which are being spearheaded by
dr anita gansha and dr adam's group
at nobuchi and their collaborators who
have a long history of research in ghana
and other countries in sub-saharan
africa
to track monitor diagnose and study the
spread
of drug resistant malaria as well as
identify
novel approaches for vaccine design as
well as the interaction between malaria
host
vectors and pathogen to help conduct
such research
the omits logic genomics program
was the second phase that started on
march 12
2021 in this second phase of training
which is currently ongoing participants
are learning about
concepts and analytical tools used to
study
genomic variation in infectious diseases
each week participants are meeting
online to discuss
various aspects of ngs data processing
genomic data analysis and interpretation
so one of the major focus will be on the
application of bioinformatics to malaria
related research where we will be
looking at the efficacy of
vaccines and drugs associated with
resistance and the complexity of host
pathogen vector interaction
for this purpose our team has already
prepared a number of research
data repositories and databases to help
the participants
identify high impact data sets for
analysis
and we will also discuss various
applications of genomics to the study of
sars koftu
where selective pressures on various
proteins will lead to the emergence of
new variants some changes are already
being
seen as a result of increased immunity
vaccination
and other host pathogen dynamics so this
program which is the omics logic
transcriptomics
and starting on april 16th we'll discuss
the various aspects of
rna-seq analysis and how this field of
bioinformatics
continues to evolve in the context
of infectious diseases
and now i want to
launch a poll that you can see right on
your screen
so this poll will help us know a little
bit more about you
and i will then continue with the
program
so the poll has a few questions for
everybody that we would like you to take
the first question is your interest in
learning ngs data analysis
so if you want to gain a basic
understanding of
ngs if you want to become an expert if
you want to work on a project on
ngstate analysis or you want to learn
to help teach your own students so you
can fill in any of these
four steps the other question is
which area of research you want to apply
ngs transcriptomic data analysis
too the first is infectious disease the
second
is agriculture third neuroscience
precision oncology and others
so if you have any other areas that you
would want to use
rna-seq for or are interested in using
and learning about rna-seq please put
those areas down
in the charts we have only listed some
of the major
areas you can also list other areas are
interested in working for example
someone was
asking about food so if you're
interested in
errors like that please put them down in
the chat box as you're continuing to
use this poll the third question is how
many time
how much time will you be able to
dedicate for engine state analysis
training per week
so we just have an average here please
feel free to comment
or choose any of these
hours that are mentioned here the last
question
is what ng's data analysis research
you're familiar with
first is single cell transcriptomics
non-coding rna
mrna you or you are a beginner and would
like to learn more
i will just keep this poll on for a
minute
and then go back to the presentation
and please continue to put in any other
questions that you may have
in the chat box while we have this whole
life
right now so that we can
also learn more about you in case we
have not covered those questions right
here so sundas if you have a question
can you please put them down in the chat
box thank you
so i would be ending the poll right now
i hope i'm not able to see the poll
votes i hope that eliot
you can confirm that currently
about 80 have voted of the current
participants
so uh maybe just leave it for
you know just one or two more minutes
okay okay
uh yeah karim so i will be able to share
with you some research papers using tbr
info give me just some time
so after i speak i would be able to
share with you
i will post it right on the chat box so
that everybody can see
the research papers published using t
buying for portal thank you
okay it looks like we we have most of
the answers captured
thank you so much india for the
confirmation so i'm ending the poll here
and continuing right now
what you see on the screen are some of
the questions
like the answer to this questions that
you have given to us so
when you have filled up the form to join
this webinar we asked you what is your
own interest
in learning about rna-seq
so these are some of the replies that we
have received
so these replies go as application of
rna-seq
in infectious disease research how to
manage large omics data in
transcriptomic
analysis getting a clarity on sequencing
methods like sanger
and ngos for research and clinical
applications
how to perform statistical differential
and regression analysis
how to leverage bioinformatics to
develop research projects and prepare
them for publication we are definitely
going to be addressing this question
during the entire training as well as
during today's session
uh the next set is this rna data
analysis processing visualization and
biological interpretation
statistical analysis methods and machine
learning for bulk and single cell
gene expression studies identification
of sample specific
over expressed genes by utilizing
unsupervised machine learning
like clustering dimensionality reduction
etc
and real-world applications of
bioinformatics and rna sequencing in
biomedical research biotechnology
and agriculture so we are going to be
taking up
these questions and answering them not
only in today's session but also in all
of the upcoming sessions in fact
the upcoming omits logic transcriptomics
program will focus on each of these
topics
in sessions like today so we are going
to be diving deep into for example we'll
have
sessions on machine learning we'll have
sessions
on different types of sequencing
techniques and they will all be
dedicated sessions
and in the later part of this
presentation today
ilya and dr mohit will take you through
these
sessions so i am not going to be talking
more about them
but what i would like to introduce you
to next is what
are these omics logic programs so if
you're joining us for the first time let
me introduce you to what omixlogic
bioinformatics training is
omixlogic is an international program
that is running in five different
regions with over 10
000 users around the world due to this
fast growth our team is working with
local and regional coordinators
that are helping refine local program
logistics and leverage our online
training resources
adapting them to the needs of students
and researchers
around the world to achieve this omits
logic
follow a project-based learning approach
using research-grade tools to analyze
data from
top peer-reviewed journals omits logic
training has been completed
by over 10 000 participants from 162
countries
in over 300 workshops for six different
specialization tracks
like oncology infectious diseases
precision medicine neuroscience data
science for biomedical data
and comprehensive training on omix data
analysis
and to answer everybody
is that whoever is interested in
research papers elia is going to be
discussing
more about research papers today
and these programs are conducted using a
combination of online sessions
like today self-guided study materials
practical assignments
for an immersive experience that has
proven to be effective in our well-known
and respected omics logic programs
so in this one month period you will
have the opportunity to
interact and collaborate with an
international team of experts
specialized in the eras of
bioinformatics and data-driven research
now let me introduce you to the program
mentors
we have dr harpreet kaur who is our
omits logic bioinformatics mentor
and trainer she will guide the sessions
and her era of specialization is in
cancer genomics
dr mohit mazumdar has a phd in
computational biology and over 10 years
of experience working with
industry and academia elia brodsky is
our ceo and co-founder his experience in
research in academia has
led to many research labs and university
collaborations and has been recognized
for the simplified approach to omics
analysis
for education now i would like to
invite our ceo ilya to talk more about
rnac data analysis in the context of
infectious diseases
over to you elia thank you
thank you very much pizza and welcome
everyone to this
webinar so i'm excited to be here and
share with you some
of the topics in this program so for
those of you who are joining
for the first time my name is elia
brodsky i'm the co-founder and ceo of
pine biotech
and what our company does is we have a
vision to enhance human health and
well-being
by enabling biological research and
discovery with relevant data
solutions and expert support and so
today what we'll talk about
is one of the areas of our activity
which is training
but essentially you'll see how this
training is effectively supporting
a number of research projects which is a
great example because this program is
supported by
both our team but also is a result of a
great collaboration with the university
of ghana
where multiple participants are focused
on developing their research projects
so this presentation that i will handle
the part that i will be doing
is going to be expanding on some of
these topics that have already been
mentioned by beefsa
because i'll be sharing a few more
details about the upcoming
omics logic training program that will
be focused on
transcriptomic data analysis and
specifically i'll try to answer the
question
how can we leverage rna-seq data
to study infectious disease from the
perspective of the host response
disease progression and host pathogen
interaction
and so what we'll do in this session is
a brief
window into the full program that will
be starting on
april 16th but we hope that we can
answer
all of your questions that are
going to lead into the practical
hands-on
sessions that will be conducted during
the training program
so let's start by asking the question
why
rna-seq other methods of quantitative
analysis of protein and
mrna expression including real-time pcr
uh western blotting microarray
hybridization assays
and other techniques are widely used in
research and clinical applications but
unlike most of these historical
platforms for clinical rna measurement
these methods are
not as rich in what type of information
they can offer about rnac data so
rna-seq is a fundamentally
an open platform technology that allows
both
quantification of known and predefined
rna species
as well as the capability to detect and
quantify rare
and novel rna transcript variants within
a sample
and so rna sequencing essentially has
revolutionized the way biologists
examine transcriptomes and has been
successfully applied
in biological research related to drug
discovery
as well as clinical development and the
basic biological research studies
and so compared to microarray-based
transcriptome profiling
rna-seq has a much wider dynamic range
and avoids some of the technical
limitations such as varying pro
performance and cross hybridization so
rnac can really
measure the expression levels of
thousands of genes simultaneously and
provide
insights into functional pathways and
the regulatory networks in biological
systems
so rna-seq really is a
platform for in-depth quantification and
analysis
of the full transcriptome
and so in application to infectious
diseases
rna sequencing allows for the detection
of
a wide variety variety of rna species
including
mrna non-coding rnas pathogen rna
chimeric gene fusion transcript isoforms
and splice variants
and provides the capability to quantify
known predefined
rna species and rare rna transcript
variants within a sample
in additional to differential expression
and detection of novel transcripts
rna-seq also supports the detection of
mutation and germline variation for
hundreds to thousands of expressed
genetic variants
facilitating assessment of allele
specific expression of these variants
so in application to disease to
infectious diseases
we can think of multiple types of
applications for example pathogen
diagnostic because many
clinically important rna viruses like
hiv
ebola west nile dengue hepatitis
uh kakasaki and influenza viruses and
severe acute respiratory syndrome like
sars mers
and source cov2 qualitative reverse
transcription
pcr assays have been developed and are
commonly used in the clinic
for viral detection and and genotyping
and so many of these targets will be
translated
into rna-based sequencing assays in the
near future so what is needed
is a deep research into the ways that
their rna is modified during infection
different disease stages and various
subpopulations
to be able to improve the diagnostic
assays that are clinically
useful pathogen mrna could be measured
for example microbial mrna could be a
useful marker of infection
as expression may improve detection in
cases of low level and persistent
infection
and also could be a better predictor of
disease compared to direct genomic
detection for example
the simple detection of human papilloma
virus hpv
dna is not sufficient to diagnose
hpv-related squamous cell carcinoma
and so rna-based diagnostic to detect
hpv have been developed
you can also measure host responses in
the form
of mrna signatures that is also going to
be useful to monitor specific types of
infections because we can detect host
response
gene expression so for example up
regulation of specific host immune
factors like
interferon beta 1 interferon lambda 2
and interferon lambda 3 has recently
demonstrated for genotype 3
hcv infection hepatitis c which is
associated with accelerated liver
fibrosis
and is an independent risk factor for
hepta cellular carcinoma
uh host microrna gene expression during
the infection response
is also proving to be a fruitful source
of potential diagnostic biomarkers for
specific infections
as well as for example latent infection
and
active disease with infections similar
to
mycobacterium tuberculosis so many
different
ways we can use rna sequencing but
as you can see before it is translated
into the clinic so before we touch on
the aspect of translational research it
really has to do with the analysis
of raw large rna sequencing data and so
one of the major challenges that i want
to talk about
is uh to create an accurate reproducible
and effective
ways of processing large-scale data sets
that represent
maybe gigabytes or even terabytes of
data
and so such large quantities really
prevent many
researchers clinicians and students to
gain a practical hands-on
feel for what is rna-seq data analysis
from the beginning to the end so what i
want to do now
is show you how this program will
help you prepare to understand some of
the flexibilities
and some of the many different options
that we have in the rna-seq methods of
processing analysis and biological
interpretation
for these large-scale studies so beeps
if you could share please the details
of uh the demo of server
t-bind for platform um please
go with me to server.tbio.info
this is a large big data processing
cloud-based tool that we have developed
and we have been using successfully
over the past uh several uh i would say
years now
to train as well as perform research
uh a variety of different tools for
processing analysis comparative analysis
hypothesis generating analysis as well
as downstream biological interpretation
so okay let me see if the details have
been posted
so okay thank you so um as you can see
here
in the chat box uh we have demo access
you'll be able to kind of sample and see
what this platform really looks like
to understand a little bit more once you
are logged in and you can see
right here uh once you are logged in
you'll be able to try some of the demo
pipelines that will give you a sense of
what are some of the options and
alternatives to rna-seq data analysis
and to see what that looks like i'm
going to use this section right here
rna-seq chip so
this is really intended for processing
and i'm going to click
on this down arrow to be able to see
what that looks like so you can see that
there's a number of demo projects and
i'm just going to use
one of these to give you a sense of what
the processing pipeline development
looks like and how we can apply it to a
variety of different topics that we'll
discuss here in just a few moments
so as we start the process of analysis
of rna-seq data it's important to keep
the logic of that analysis in mind and
basically all the processing concepts
consists of three major steps
the first one is pre-processing so we
have to clean
the raw data from all kinds of adapters
and technical variation that we want to
exclude
then mapping or alignment that could be
either to the
full transcriptome or the genome it
could actually be a combined strategy
and then quantification and this could
refer to the quantification of
known novel or alternative variations
that are referred to as isoforms
typically in this type of analysis so if
you scroll down
you'll be able to see a very simple
pipeline that we can
design and quickly execute on this cloud
server so i'm just going to click on
ok and here i'm going to be able to
select some pre-processing steps that
you can see
trim the raw reads from the fastq files
and you can read a little bit more about
this method if you scroll down
you can then see right here a next
step is going to be highlighted
automatically so you don't have to
think and really plan your analysis but
follow the step-by-step process to learn
about the inputs and outputs first
and here you'll learn about
amplification of pcr
that's called bridge amplification and
then we will
map our data using hysat2 which is
essentially in
an updated uh processing of top hat too
so here you can see some of the
important variations
in mapping that have to be considered
for example
we need to consider the different exons
in introns
as well as alternative splicing and how
that is going to be detected
in the multiple reeds typically millions
of reads that we have
per sample so here we're going to click
on ok
we can detect novel isoforms by
measuring
the splicing junctions between pieces of
reeds
and then we can actually create a
novel transcriptome annotation file
called the genome transfer file
where all of this information is going
to be stored for once we do
mapping on transcript so again we map
the raw reads we've cleaned them up
we now created those junctions and saved
all of that information
in our reference file and after we have
done that
we can now quantify this information
by preparing a table of expression and
the table of expression
is essentially a table that is already
structured so instead of individual
reads we have
samples and genes or isoforms
and we can quantify them by creating a
continuous data set
and that continuous data could now be
used
for either differential gene expression
which is downstream analysis
of genes that are up or down regulated
based on
groups of samples or what i will show
you next
are some other tools that you can use to
perform unsupervised and supervised
analysis
using a variety of machine learning
tools that would be helpful to detect
variable pattern patterns across
large data sets such as uh hundreds and
even thousands of samples
okay so here we have a sample pipeline
you can click on download pipeline
output files and just kind of see
what some of those output files are
going to look like
and once you get that table of
expression which is the major
output from this analysis you'll be able
to see
a variety of data integration data
mining
and specific virology applications for
these data sets
so here you can see supervised analysis
unsupervised analysis utilities that
allow us to do biological interpretation
and also you can see a variety of
specifically virology specific
applications but before we jump into
these let me briefly talk about
how this applies to infections caused by
different types of pathogens such as
viruses
bacteria and parasites so
when it comes to viruses we think of
them in an oversimplified
model because we think of them as single
units
that comprise a specific type of a
process
modeled after what we know about the
infection
but in reality viruses are very complex
machinery consisting of many variations
of the same
types of proteins and protein elements
and so when we think about the process
of infection one objective for rna-seq
data
is to be able to clarify and accurately
detect
the different types of interactions
happening between these
different variants of those proteins and
the host response
and essentially what the objective of
this analysis in the context of viral
infection
is to develop a data-driven model that
allows us to
identify specific elements that we can
now play around with
to determine the interaction the host
response and the variability of disease
manifestation
across many different patients right
because we can think of disease
having multiple types of outcomes
overall
and so in that process it's important to
be able to identify these specific
elements that have a major impact on
disease progression
and so you can see in this example of a
study
we can take this gene expression table
that we have prepared in the rna-seq
data processing pipeline
and then we can start differentiate
between different stages of disease
progression
eliminating using knock-down technology
or eliminating specific genes from the
viral infection
and measuring the differentiation
between immune responses
and so once we understand those
differences to be present in the data
we can start our comparative analysis
and so when we think about the
comparative analysis in many cases this
comparative analysis
is added to the end of the pipeline that
we just prepared
you can see that it allows us to ask the
question
what are the specific genes that are
affected by the difference
in condition measured perhaps in
multiple samples across a couple of
groups
and so when we think about that we are
really focusing on
extracting the specific genes that have
a measurable and statistically
reliable differentiation or
differentially expressed genes
now in many cases when we think of this
simple design for the experiment it
doesn't really capture
a variety of factors and how they
influence
the specific type of conditions that we
might observe
and so a lot of times we can use more
advanced methods like
factor regression analysis to be able to
identify
how the infection process can
be impacted by age different treatment
different comorbidities and other
factors
included in the experiment design this
is especially
critical when we deal with a real
patient population
because this real patient population is
going to be affected by multiple factors
that we need to consider in our model
ultimately once we have the p-values
and the specific full change values
from this comparative analysis we can
now start asking a biological question
of how can we map the differential
gene expression or variable gene
expression
across different biological pathways and
so an important step here is to
correlate the
ids of individual genes with specific
annotation into gene ontology terms
and pathway that we can find on such
repositories as keg or david and so
we'll also talk about how we can
leverage these applications
to be able to uh analyze what
is the biological uh kind of summary
of the identified genes and so what
we'll do
in this program that we've been talking
about is really
try to focus on each one of these steps
i know that i'm going really fast right
now for the purpose of time
and we're going to look at a variety of
factors
that you'll be able to learn and
practice in a hands-on fashion and so
this will include relevant tools like we
saw
including tools for big data analysis
and tools for
downstream analysis using r and python
we'll talk about different types of
applications to bulk
and single cell rnac data and we'll also
talk about
a variety of ways that we can
use the methods that we have discussed
so far
to apply them to individual projects or
use cases for rna-seq in infectious
diseases
and so because this project is a
collaboration with the naguchi
uh memorial institute for medical
research at the university of ghana
as well as our collaborators at the
tower bioinformatics research center
which is at university of haifa in
israel
i want to present you with some case
studies that we are working on
to make them ready for this session
that's going to be starting
on april so that you can have a
perspective
of what types of project examples we're
going to be using
and how you can apply this to the
specifics of
your maybe ideas about rna-seq and
infectious diseases
so this is an article that was published
in 2015 but
with the emergence of source code 2 has
become
significantly relevant to i think what
we are trying to understand about the
source code 2 covet 19
infection where we see how
a specific gene p53 down
regulates sars corona virus replication
and is targeted by the stars unique
domain
and pop pro via e3 ubiquitin ligase
rchy1
and so this publication shows us how we
can
analyze rna-seq data to understand the
interaction between the specific
proteins that are produced by the
pathogen by the virus in this case and
the regular pathways
that are designed in the host system to
reduce
replication of the pathogen it's
important also that
this same analytical technique can help
us differentiate between responses
to a variety of different respiratory
infections
and here you can see an example from a
geodataset accession number gse
two seven 149273 which provides us with
a data set that compares
multiple types of respiratory infections
and how we can measure
the responses to those infections
understanding of variability between
different agents that cause the
infection itself
another example i think that is very
clear
is how we can use the rna-seq data from
both
bulk and single cell rna-seq data
to understand the imbalanced host
response to source code 2
which drives the development of more
severe covet 19
infection so as you can see on this
image
you can see that there is essentially a
typical
response to corona virus or to
respiratory infections
and then there is this specific acute
sar
specific response and so we can measure
the inflammation
and the different markers of
inflammation to really understand
where the difference is including what
types of
cells can that difference be measured in
in a more specific way we'll also see
how
a very similar process to what we
observe in source code 2
is actually common between a variety of
other types of pathogens
for example here you can see ebola and
marburg viruses
actually use a similar response evasion
immune response evasion technique
by targeting specific pathways on the
host immune side
to enable effective replication
and especially infection of other
tissues
that are typically more protected by
these tissue specific interferon
responses
another focus for this program is going
to be on malaria
and so what we'll talk about are several
examples where we can look
at cell specific immune responses to the
different stages of replication for the
pathogen so malaria is a parasite and
goes through these important cycles of
development
that are causing different types of
infection
and have to be targeted and detected
accurately which can be done
using rna-seq data and another
important aspect of all of these studies
is that in many cases
when we talk about these translational
research studies
they are conducted at cell line animal
model
as well as patient level responses and
so we need to understand that
our data represents accurately what
happens
in a system and that system is
applicable to
the patient response so ultimately what
we'll do in this program
is we will take a look at these examples
and we'll see how rna-seq data
is a great example of multi-atomic
studies that allow us to use
bioinformatics for clinical diagnostic
and therapeutic response studies that
enable
a better understanding of infectious
disease
and prepare us for the next phase
of designing repurposing and
appropriately targeting specific
pathogen driven diseases and so we'll
at the end talk about how such data
could be integrated by using
uh high throughput screening
measurement of immune responses and host
responses to different treatments and
different
ways that the pathogen infects the host
to essentially enable a faster
and more accurate application of novel
therapeutics
and repurpose drugs to treat these
infectious diseases
that are currently representing a huge
burden
on whole sections of the population
so hopefully this provides a clear
perspective on how rna-seq data could be
used
in application to study and translate
research insights
into practical use and now i briefly
want to touch on some
specific sessions that we've designed as
a part of this program
to introduce you to rna-seq or to
transcriptomic data analysis so
first of all to give you an overview i
want to introduce you
to an important resource where we will
be hosting
a lot of the asynchronous materials that
you can leverage
already even before the program starts
to get a sense
of what are some of these methods of
analysis and what are some of the
applications
in processing analysis
visualization as well as interpretation
of rna-seq
data for bulk rna-seq and single cell
rna-seq so here i have a link to the
older
portal that we are slowly moving away
from
but it's still live and available and
thank you biebsef for posting this new
link
which is learn that omixlogic.com so let
me show you briefly
uh this portal so that all of you can
take a look at what's there
so this is the omix logic learn portal
and this portal is going to allow anyone
to
register for free so you can create your
account for free there's no payment
involved
using different social media uh tools
and uh
you can also create your own path uh uh
password
and after you log in you essentially
gain access
to a variety of coursework
which include practical assignments on
our platform
as well as using r and python
so here you can see some of those
examples
of coding and different types of
example projects that we will be going
through in this program and i think
beeps that will
take some time at the end of this
session to discuss the process of
registration
and what types of resources are going to
be included
so as you go through these asynchronous
courses
it's important that a lot of them
include some practical
review tutorials and examples
similar to what we did today but you
will also
find different variations of those
pipelines that you could compare and
contrast
to really understand the significance of
the specific
methods of analysis as well as the
specific
logic behind this analysis and that's
why
we call this omix logic so it really
expands on the logic of when
we are applying different methods why we
are applying different methods
and how to do this in such a way that we
can get
reproducible results for our analysis
and again the purpose is to provide you
with a full overview from
basic processing to biological
interpretation
so we will start on april 16th and we
will
talk about processing transcriptomic
data that will include
a detailed resource that you can take
home with you and continue practicing
even after the program is over we will
highlight
important terminology for you to know
and we will compare different methods
of rna quantification we will then
perform
different types of pipelines to
understand the logic
and prepare the table of expression
after we get that table of expression
we'll talk about
different ways of visualizing our data
to understand
what are the important considerations
for transcript and isoform expression
we'll talk about detection of viral
pathogens in rna-seq data from the host
and we'll talk about
the different immune responses as
examples that you can study
and compare between different pipelines
we'll then talk about differential gene
expression including
practical assignments in r using methods
like dc2 and edge
r so you will see how we talk about the
concept behind it
what is the statistical principle how do
we apply it specifically to data sets
like gene expression which contain
thousands and thousands of genes and
we'll talk about important methods of
data preparation
for downstream analysis that include
normalization and log scale
transformation
we'll also practice how to do this using
our coding
exercises that you can do right from
within the browser so you are not
spending
the significant time it typically takes
to install
all the necessary software and can
actually test whether the analysis that
you are performing
is reproducible and accurate according
to predefined test results
we'll also talk about more advanced
analysis
including anova regression false
discovery rate and what are some of the
terms that you need to
know to be able to apply the statistical
tests in a more reproducible and
accurate way
and we'll talk about biological
interpretation including annotation of
pathways like keg geo or gene expression
omnibus data sets and annotation using
genomology terms and david
we'll also talk about how the
interpretation of those biology can help
us understand the specific
properties of protein protein
interaction
and the important variation that could
be detected
using gene expression data and so to do
that
we'll use methods like gene set
enrichment analysis
and the specific types of settings that
you have to
have so that you can apply this
effectively
to interpret complex regulatory pathways
of immune response and regulation of
specific processes that are hijacked by
pathogens as they cause disease
importantly with so much data and so
much variation
we do face a growing challenge of big
data and so we'll talk about
unsupervised methods of data mining or
unsupervised
methods of machine learning that include
clustering and there are many different
methods of clustering
including clustering that is
specifically designed for big data sets
as well as methods for dimensionality
reduction
that include principal component
analysis t-sne
and others and so what you will find
on our practical platform
the learn omixlogic.com are a variety of
tutorials to practice
the packages for visualization and
analysis including t-bioinfo-based
methods
that you can first learn the logic
behind and then
see the scripting components that can
help you make this
analysis modified to maybe present
specific types of visualizations in your
project
we'll also talk about different methods
of supervised machine learning or
classification and feature selection and
so there's
a variety of different classification
models that you can use
and so we will talk about how you can
apply data mining
together with classification to achieve
optimal results
in terms of your accuracy as well as to
understand so make it
interpretable how can we understand the
specific methods
and when to apply what type of methods
or maybe
what are some of the considerations
between your training
and test as well as validation data sets
importantly as you probably all know
there is a huge excitement about the
opportunities that single cell rna seq
data can offer
especially in the context of immune
sponsors where a variety of different
cells
are responsible for different stages of
mounting an immune response
to a particular infection as well as to
understand the differences of disease
progression
across many stages of disease
manifestations or clinical
manifestations of disease
and so we'll talk about the growing
numbers of
methodologies for preparation of single
cell
libraries that include 10x genomics
and other types of uh all kinds of
preparation techniques for scrna seek or
single cell transcriptomics we'll talk
about
the logic behind building a pipeline for
single cell analysis
and we'll also discuss how you can build
a pipeline
to essentially analyze integrate and
visualize single cell rna-seq data
without trying to open those tables in
excel
which i know we all like but it becomes
more and more difficult as you have
thousands and thousands of samples
across thousands and thousands of genes
so we'll talk about how to prepare a
pipeline
without necessarily having to deal with
these tables
hands on on your computer so using
cloud-based tools
so again let me briefly um answer
some of the questions uh so i i'm done
with my part of the presentation before
we move on to
dr mohit mazumder who will talk about
independent project design
using this program i want to make sure
that i answer
any technical questions that you might
have about my part of the presentation
so uh beeps if you could let me know if
there are any specific questions that i
need to answer
about my part of the presentation before
we move on
currently elia i do not see any
questions related uh
to your part of the presentation but we
definitely had
those uh requests about uh
learning to use rna-seq in other areas
for example rna there was a question
from priyan who
had asked earlier is change in rna
sequencing
in some microbes like sarskoftu
give a great impact in their nature and
behavior
okay so i think related to source cove
too we actually will have a whole
series of examples as i mentioned before
where a lot is really not known so i
think that
we are basing a lot of our understanding
of the immune responses on kind of a
very typical
model based understanding of the
interaction between the pathogen and the
host
now obviously as you get deeper into the
data you start realizing how variable
the disease
is how it varies between different cell
types
tissues different patients and different
other factors that we are not
considering when we study the infection
in
cell line models of infection
so there's a lot to learn about in terms
of what rna-seq
can teach us about the process of
infection and i think there's a lot of
novel
insights that you can extract from data
sets that are available online
in public repositories and so i think
that to answer that comprehensively
we need to talk about more specific
examples
these examples relate to how the
infection happens in different
cells it talks about how the infection
happens in patients
you have animal models that represent
some features
of human disease but not all of them and
so i think that it's important to
kind of find the rich repositories of
source code to rna-seq data sets and
start asking those specific questions
um and and uh so i will pass it on to dr
mohit mazumdar who will speak about some
of these examples and how
we go about preparing uh project
examples
uh but uh briefly i see a question here
from uh asia who's asking will you be
going from basic rna extraction to
sequencing in detail
and you don't have any uh prior
knowledge but your project includes
transcriptomic analysis of code 19.
exactly yeah so we're going to be going
from the very basics
of what is the method of data
preparation
how do you prepare it and what will some
of those example data sets in public
repositories what do they really
represent
to the basic steps that anyone including
a complete novice can reproduce
on their own so i think this is very
appropriate for those of you that are
interested in applying rnac data to
source code 2
or other pathogens but you can join this
program
and essentially have access to the
synchronous resources that will include
all of the session recordings that you
can watch in your own time
they will include practical assignments
that you can complete on your own
schedule you're not required to complete
them
for specific dates but you will benefit
from live interactive sessions
where you can ask questions if you don't
understand something or you can practice
together with a mentor
now beeps will speak about this later
but we do also offer
a private mentor support so you can get
access to a mentor who can troubleshoot
any data set for you
or help you get unstuck with many of the
technical challenges that you
might likely face as you deal with real
research data so maybe to
make sure that we get to all parts of
this presentation
i want to introduce you to other uh
trainers in this program
who are harpreet kawar dr harprika or
she has a phd in bioinformatics
her expertise is in cancer genomics but
she has been preparing
several of the example projects that we
will be going through
and so you will hear from her a lot
about the technical part of rna-seq
processing
analysis visualization and
interpretation
and then dr mohit mazumdar is our
omixlogic project mentor who
helps develop projects that are
independent so
many of you who are working on
independent projects will be able to
leverage his many years of expertise and
background in many publications that he
co-authored
or was the lead author on to really
understand
how bioinformatics can lead to a
successful research
and industry career uh so dr mazumdar i
will pass it on to you
to take it on from here thank you
thank you ilya and vipsha for the
overview of this
logic training program for anyone
joining for the first time
my name is mohit mazundar and let me
share the screen
so and thanks for joining the session
and staying till now
so yeah there you go
right so as i was telling you that i am
one of the global rep
representative of pine biotech and one
of the co-mentors
of this of the so mixed logic program
and i'll be available throughout this
program to help
guide students propose and work on
bioinformatics ngs projects
but today i wanted to talk about the
structure of the omics logic uh this
omix logic transcriptomics program
so in this program along with the live
sessions the participants will be
will be able to learn through the
interactive and
engaging content on the transcriptomics
data analysis
so this transcriptomics data analysis
program is a special program by
uh our omics logic team and this program
has been taken by
thousands of users and has evolved as
one of the most
reviewed uh program uh in our structures
so uh to tell you more about the
resources and the omis logic program and
as well as like how this omixlogic
program
will be translating into a research
project
so that would be the next part of this
small presentation that i have
prepared for all of you so omixlogic is
an
integrated uh educational and research
platform
so this research platform is a place
where student and faculty
can learn conduct uh research and
collaborate
so this platform combines introductory
coursework
on biological data analysis and data
management and
analysis tool that you can take any time
like
at your own uh at your own pace
because those will be available for all
the participants throughout this period
of the
program so this learning and this
learning material
consists of variety of topics like india
discuss such as viral
viral transcriptomics analysis and then
how it applies to molecular medicine
so we will be doing practical exercises
where we'll be introducing basic
statistical concepts
uh and advanced analytical methods like
how do you integrate data how do you do
machine learning
how do you do network analysis and then
we will be also doing hands-on
assignments that are based on this
visual interface
that links together like individual
algorithms
into bioinformatics pipelines so let's
uh
talk a little bit about the
bioinformatics pipeline so
one of the advantage of of learning
through this is that
you are learning from workflows that
allows participants to learn
about complex bioinformatics pipelines
and algorithms and their outputs
right so this transcriptomics program
exposes the participants
to a wider range of transcriptomics data
analysis
including the analysis of highly
anticipated single sentence gene
expression data as india mentioned
so this pro the focus of this program is
to train participants
to learn and apply trust atomics data
analysis using example data sets
and projects that we have prepared and
then
like once you have gone through that
entire process
and to be able to communicate this uh
communicate this outcome of the research
so we start from the training
basic starting from the very basic and
then we transform
into this learning process of how we do
tr uh different types of
transcriptomics data analysis by
learning through like
several of the published projects and
also different data sets that are coming
up
and after that uh after that process the
next step is to
get feedback so this is this program
uses a strong
feedback mechanism where we get feedback
from the experts
as well as international
team which actually has expertise
in different fields of research so
to get that feedback we kind of once we
get that feedback
we kind of improve the project so how do
we improve maybe those feedbacks that we
get
they include information from the
literature that we we should
look into this sort of article that
would help our analysis
and also to you know strategically
design those workflows
and analysis step so that's the second
that's the stage after
you kind of start developing a proposal
so many of our parties part
past participants have gone through this
entire process of starting from courses
and then next to and then next to work
on uh example data sets
and then uh exploring the public data
sets to be able to come up with you know
these sort of posters conference posters
and then
work on a publication so i will be today
uh you know talk
uh will be i will be today talking about
the process of
a proposal to publication or to complete
a research
uh study right so
as i was telling you this entire process
of learning uh has been
really effective for students who are
interested in learning about
ngs data analysis and then who wants
also for those who wants to apply it for
a noble bioinformatics research project
so we have had students
who came from uh without any background
in bioinformatics
who were undergraduate students then we
have faculty who came with uh
who are working on molecular biology but
want to develop expertise in
bioinformatics then we also have had uh
people from different companies who are
working uh in a research setup or who
are
interested to do this sort of research
that would help them
contribute to what is ongoing with all
these different types of
diseases and the problems that we are
facing in our health care system
so this program will help those who are
interested to apply
these learning into a noble
bioinformatics project
as well as for faculty i mean to use
this research
resources and conduct independent
workshops for university students and
also to do their
own independent you know research so the
materials we have been
uh that we have collected they have been
reviewed by faculty and the students
from top
uh us and international universities so
this kind of feedback uh actually
demonstrate that the learning could be
very effective if done properly and also
like even transformational
so that's what i was coming at to so the
process of
next like i we went through the process
of basic
learning then from basic to advanced
statistical uh learning
and then applying it to some example
projects
and then moving into a research proposal
so once you have a research proposal and
that has been
have had the feedback the next step
would be to you know
to be able to work on that so after
successfully completing this omics logic
transcriptomics program
program the participants will be
eligible to join the
research fellowship program so the
research fellowship program is
is you know designed sorry sorry about
that
so the research fellowship program is
actually designed
to help students uh learn and apply this
bioinformatics projects
uh by applying their learning into a
bioinformatics projects where we work
with them
uh we work the mentor work with them and
we work with them throughout the
entire process helping them how to apply
bioinformatics research
into a real life situation or real life
problem
so to learn about this entire process of
registration you have to start with the
omics logic this omixologic
transcriptomics program
if you're interested in ngs data
analysis so to learn about this
registration process
i would like to now invite uh miss
viesha
so over to you miss biksha
and thank you there are any questions
about this section about the projects
please feel free to reach out to me
and also beepsha if you can uh maybe
say if there are any questions related
please let me know
yeah dr um that there's one question
is asking will you be discussing gene
expression in chronic non-communicable
diseases
uh such as cancer in this training this
is
uh my era of interest
yeah so the examples that we have uh
on our platform that includes like if
you take the transcriptomics one course
the example data says that that we are
using there is the mouse pdx model so
it's a breast cancer
uh mouse uh mouse data so we also
have like a cell line data that you can
like learn from so we have a lot of
cancer examples that you can leverage
so when you join this program if you are
interested in a very specialized
cancer training then we will be able to
help you out with the
available public data sets as well as
there are examples there are a lot of
example data
that we have collected for cancer
research and that uses the
transcriptomics data analysis
and you will be able to learn from those
as well
okay so thank you uh so much dr mazumdar
so i'll continue
by sharing my screen here and walk
everybody through the registration
resources and the different aspects of
the program and i know that there are a
lot of questions that i would like to
address in this part
so please continue to post your
questions in the
chat box so for different parts of this
program we'll utilize
different resources that you all have
had the
chance to have a look at like the learn
or mix logic platform the t by info
platform
so to start with please continue to
register
for free on learn.ormixlogic
and i will take a moment in a minute to
do that with you together
and throughout the course you will also
be given directions to access the
t bio info platform for processing
and analysis of rna seq data like
elia showed you today the platform
includes demo pipelines
again which was demonstrated today as
well as data management
and analysis cloud infrastructure to run
bioinformatics pipelines
so different stages of analysis are
performed in different sections of this
multi-omics platform
and for each participant who are joining
in today's session or who will be
joining in the program
sorry not in today's session will be
joining the full program
they will have an educational access to
the platform
which means that they would be able to
use
public domain data sets upload them to
the platform
and then work on the output to
understand
or answer any kind of biological
questions that they are trying to solve
which dr mohit touched upon briefly in
the research fellowship or the project
aspect of the program
and we will also have exercises designed
to explain
coding in r and python
so from the very basics to the cutting
edge
like loading transformation
visualization as well as complex
discovery of patterns in real data sets
used by researchers to study and
understand biological phenomena at the
molecular
level we will learn about important
concepts within
infectious diseases such as the central
dogma
the immunology of infection and disease
progression central dogma of molecular
biology
immunology of infection molecular
disease markers and stages
host pathogen interaction response
heterogeneity
gene regulation target pathways as well
as
use bioinformatics analysis methods and
resources like how to process
ngs data variant calling rna-seq
pipeline statistical analysis machine
learning then how to annotate
and also we'll use example projects data
sets and methods of data management
to understand the efficacy of infection
drug treatment
sars ebola and malaria example we'll use
public domain repositories like
ncbi virus geo malaria gen
we'll understand what are the different
clinical risk factors and
outcomes and how to find and organize
this data for your own study and how to
structure a bioformatix project
so these are going to be the program
objectives
so once you complete the program these
are some of the learning
outcomes you will know how to do the
following read and understand
bi-informatics literature
perform basic ngs analysis processing
steps
analyze data and form hypothesis
prepare data for machine learning
cross-check signals with gene databases
know what type of data is required to
answer
scientific questions create your own
bioinformatics analysis
presentation of your results in an
organized way
so we will be focusing on all of these
and all of these skill sets are
essential in bioinformatics
and can be also translated to some other
fields as well
so i have a question for you what skill
set or
area would you want to learn within the
field of research like say
infectious diseases or rna-seq for
agriculture any other thing please put
in one
word or sentence in the chat box
and shortly i would be
replying to some of the questions in the
chat box
okay so asia says that tb
tuberculosis and sars cof2
anybody else is interested in any other
diseases so you can continue to put
those down
in the chat box so amin ali says cancer
sadaf khan says oncogenics
castros is sepsis cancer are using says
alzheimer's interesting arizona i will
point out
point you out your resource on
alzheimer's that we have
as well as we have several resources on
cancer
uh which dr mohit spoke about earlier
so okay thank you all for sharing so if
anybody else wants to add to this
then please continue to uh post them
down in the chat box
so are they doing says biomarkers of
okay i'm not reading the scientific name
bladder cancer then sheriff hamed is on
malaria and dengue so malaria
is going to be one of the topics that we
will be covering most
as we are doing this as a part of a
collaborative program
with mobuchim okay so we have some
tuberculosis sars cof2
then canine parvo viral entireties
that came to me privately in the chat
lillian is interested in starscoff too i
think these are some
very interesting areas and i think we
would be covering and in fact we have
worked on
several of these errors with other
participants as well
so i will take you quickly through
some of these resources and show you
like you know how
you can effectively utilize this so
someone had asked me that when we would
be getting a certificate or not at the
end of the program yes
so you would be receiving a certificate
when you complete
this program
so now let me show you how to register
for the program and also
uh show you some of the resources right
so she can't let me show you the free
fee structure as well as all the
questions okay
so sadaf all the programs are not free
the program itself is not free there is
a fee
to join the program so let me take you
to
understanding how everything is working
so if you have already registered for
this program you would have received an
email that has all the details on how to
join the program
so that email states this link which is
called transcriptomics.omitslogic.com
so if you come with me to this uh link
i'm posting it on the chat box you'll be
able to see that
this is the page and here you see that
it's starting on 16th of april and
ending on 20th of may it is a one month
program
we'll have sessions which spread out
over a week so we do not have sessions
every day
each of these sessions are only one hour
sessions like we are having today
and here are some of the different
session dates
so we'll have a session on april 16th
the next session will be on april 19th
april 23rd so on and so forth
you can check out this entire
dates here and continue to read about
them
i will show you what are the different
registration costs and
also explain to you how to register for
here
we also have an ongoing 40 percent
discount going on
and i'll show you in your email how you
can find that as well
so you will notice once you click on get
started there are different
costs for this program so it's the same
program
i'll make sure to help you understand
what are these different
costs about so the basic program the
basic cost covers
all of those things that we have
discussed today so you will be able to
attend
the full program you will be able to
access
all of the resources mentioned during
this entire one month of training
so what are these additional two
intermediate and advanced
licenses for so this
intermediate license comes with an
additional mentor support so if you are
interested in working closely with a
mentor
or you feel that you need extra sessions
to help you
uh with this so we will be able to guide
you
in the intermediate course because it
includes mentor support
while the advanced license gives you
access to 30 more days
so you would see here that the program
ends on 20th may
but if you are taking the advanced
license the program will end
on the 20th of june for you because you
will get 30 days
more to continue with your project so
at this part of the session it includes
if you are
going to if you think that you are going
to be working on a project related to
say infectious diseases
or any of the related topics that we
will cover and
you want to do that project then we
recommend that you
take up this license because that will
give you enough chance to first cover
the training which both of these
licenses will cover and then also go for
a project on your own which will be your
own novel project and it will be
supported by
our mentors as well as some of the
research fellows who work with
us so these are the references and
just to let everybody know we have a 40
percent discount running
right at the moment so if you notice
your email there is this
discount code that you can enter right
around
here so if you put early bird discount
and apply
it you would be able to see the
difference in pricing and
uh check out with it this discount would
not be valid
beyond next monday so the discount
will continue to grow smaller like the
next discount would be 30
so please make sure of the maximum
discount that is available right now
so this is the early bird discount that
is only available
and also let me answer some of these
questions before i move on
so can you tell me job chances after
this course completion so shashikan
to answer that question i would have to
tell you that
applying for a job it's definitely
dependent
on what kind of job you're applying for
what is the exact
criteria that your employer has
so but what we have seen and i will
introduce you
and ask you to follow us on linkedin is
that
there are a lot of participants who have
completed
many programs like this not just
transcriptomics we have several
different programs
and we continue to share about their
progress here
and in addition to that i will introduce
you to some of the research
projects so let me find the research
projects it is right here
so these are some of the novel research
projects and these projects have been
proposed by
participants by students some of them
who are also high school students for
example you can see
this project is by amelia truong she's a
high school student
so these students continue to do the
projects and they continue to work with
us in mentor support
so i do not know uh whether you are
going to
get a job or not what we do here is
prepare you
for a different sets of skills that you
acquire if you learn about
rna-seq and what we are trying to do
here is teach you the logic of analysis
so once you learn the logic you can
apply
that learning to any different kinds of
projects different types of data
and work there so that is the skill set
we hope that you are able to develop
over time
so thank you and karine's question
is there any difference between the
research fellowship and the advanced
option
uh definitely there is a difference
between the research fellowship
and the advanced option so the research
fellowship is a three-month program
completely where we are only working on
projects so most of these projects which
are here
that you see here these are all our
research fellows who have completed
these projects
in a three months or a six-month time
period it's a very dedicated
program where you are required
but they are required to definitely do
their tasks
complete those it's a week-to-week and
very intensive kind of a training
and we are involved in those research
projects
in the capacity as mentors and help to
guide these research projects and in
fact the research fellows are
also supposed to present these projects
on different sessions that we have from
time to time
so that is also one of the necessary
uh aspects of when it comes to the
research project
okay i'll post the discount code one
more time in the chat box it's called
early bird 40 so let me just
post the discount code in the chat box
for everybody again
in case someone did not receive it and
you can enter it
right here so let me select any of these
options enter it right here
and apply it and see so you see that the
price is 90 dollars available
only till monday next week so please
make sure to take
advantage of the opportunity that is
there
and let me also answer some of these
other questions that are there
so cutting let me know if i have been
able to completely answer your questions
if you have any other question i would
like to request everybody
to reach out to me marketing at pine dot
bio is the email id
lina you can opt for the
fellowship program at any point of time
we really keep it open
you can uh it is up to you which of
these
uh method which of these licenses or
another methods but which of these
licenses you are choosing from which
program this is completely up to you
so depending on what you require at the
moment
you can do this
and answering not question do we need
advanced laptop pc or the general one is
enough
so this is the most interesting part now
so uh
as elia showed you the t by info
platform so let me take you back to
server.tbio
so this is a cloud-based platform which
means that you do not need to install
any kind of software or hardware in your
own local system if you have an internet
connection
and of course everybody has a browser it
can be chrome or it can be any other
browsers you can utilize
it in the browser we definitely
recommend google chrome for the best
performance
and you will be able to analyze very
large data sets if each participant will
have
five terabytes of space in the cloud
to work on different kinds of public
domain data sets and you will be able to
go through these different
areas so elia has only demonstrated
the demo pipelines but in the sessions
we'll also work with some of these
other pipelines that are here and also
the pipelines here
and we will be doing that in depth with
you we'll have
uh sessions and we'll work together with
you
in fact in case you have any questions
or you are stuck somewhere so
we'll work through with you through
those problems during the sessions that
we have
so karen yeah you can definitely join
the
fellowship program without a predefined
project at hand
okay okay
uh i'm going to be uh addressing some of
the questions
okay so karim yes you can join without
so many times it happens that
some of the research fellows are joining
in for the first time
they have no idea what they would want
to work on
but maybe just an area so someone would
say that you know i'm interested in
cancer
so then we help them define you know
what type of cancer
because just seeing cancer is a it's a
very large question and it has so many
things like you can do it can be breast
cancer liver cancer someone mentioned
bladder cancer
so there is so many opportunities that
are there
so you can define that during the
program we will definitely work with you
on a first month would be spending on
training you so that is helpful
okay and okay so phoebe is here
monthly limitation when you register for
90 dollars there's no monthly limitation
or i
do not get your question like the whole
program will run for one month
only with the advanced license someone
is able to get an additional 30 months
that is completely
an individual's personal choice
uh individual's personal choice to go
forward with that kind of training
and uh for amen what are the timings so
the timing for each session
is uh at 10 a.m cst
telling cst is 8 30 p.m ist
and 4 p.m wat so please
try to convert 10am cst to your local
time
so that you are able to understand what
is it because i cannot
uh tell the timing for all the time
zones so please convert
10 amc st which is central standard time
to your local time and if you're not
able to join the session so
all sessions are recorded and the video
is shared with our
participants privately so you will be
able to review the videos later as well
uh so sashikanth we typically
work with data that has already been
sequenced
so we are not able to arrange for a wet
lab practice session
and it is also difficult to arrange a
wet lab
session because you see now right now we
have
participants who are joining us from all
over the world so if it's wet lab and if
you have to do it in a particular
laboratory it also limits uh you know
who can join that session
with us right so uh we will focus
more on ngs data and that is what we
have our expertise
in
okay so your interest is in food so
typically what we try to do with the
sessions and if you
also take a look at the courses here so
let me actually
log in together with you and take you
through the courses
so if you are here on learn.omicslogic
maybe this will give you
a better idea so please come with me
and kylie i would be able to answer your
question
so if you're logged in using either
creating an account
so you'll be taken to this course part
now what we have done here there are
some question
courses which are absolutely free while
there are some courses
which would be marked with a star so
those forces are paid
so if you look here under
transcriptomics the first course which
is the biology of
transcription is uh is a free
lesson so you would be able to start
learning from the very basic
so once you start learning about rna-seq
like
really learning like how how do rna-seq
work what are the different
uh areas you i think you can apply it to
the research question
that you are trying to solve and in any
case you are always
welcome to reach out to us if you have
like any specific
project idea or any biological question
you're trying to solve and need some
help
so i would again be leaving the email id
of both myself and also dr
mohit in case you want to reach out to
us for more explanation
later on and we can help you with that
specific question
because again agriculture is also quite
a broad topic so
what specific question it is it would be
very very helpful so shashi shashikan
again this is the ebook that we have we
welcome you to go through this ebook
you will have several videos several
steps and you see
once you complete you can click on next
and it will take you to the next part
and i hope that you are able to learn
from
this as well so there are several
courses here
most of the lessons here are available
for free
and you can take those lessons right
away
like starting today and you do not need
to wait till the transcriptomics program
what we will do in the sessions here are
introduced participants who are
interested in learning more about the
hands-on analysis
and working through different projects
to help them through those different
sessions and courses
but this platform is open for you to
go ahead and take a lesson form
okay so i hope that i do not miss out on
any questions now let me
also introduce you again to some of the
resources that i think you should check
out
so this is our linkedin group that i
welcome again everybody to join
because we keep sharing many interesting
things on our group like here i found
this very interesting
which talks about different algorithms
like unsupervised
and supervised machine learning and what
are their
example usages similarly you will find
that other members also continue to
share interesting topics here
so please continue to join our linkedin
group here
and we also have a facebook page that
you can
find here and i have shared with you
both the links
and i hope that everybody is clear on
the registration process
if you still have any more doubts and if
you still want me to go through this
please post that down in the chat box
now
let me quickly also talk a little bit
about
scholarship opportunities so we
also offer scholarships for students
and this is a scholarship is
applied so that students who are not
able to
join this program or afford the cost
they can
make availability of the scholarship
opportunity
and to do this you will have to fill out
a form
for the scholarship and in this form you
will have
these fields which will ask you to
mention references
once you fill out that form we will be
setting up a meeting with one of your
reference
and
depending on that what we would do is
that based
on that meeting we would be able
to understand whether you are going to
be offered the scholarship or not
so it's an intensive process so if you
are going to apply for the scholarship
we recommend
that you start right now and right away
so somebody has said that some students
have low
cgpa okay it is okay even if you have
low cgpa but if you
uh show that you are interested in the
scholarship
and you follow through some of the tasks
that we assign you
when we are doing that interview with
you it is very necessary that you may
still get the
scholarship option and reference
means that
someone from your institute like he or
she can be
your teacher he or she can be your
department head
please do not bring your friends at
references
so um because we would not be taking
appear as a reference but reference is
typically someone who is
teaching you and knows you and can
help us understand that you would be
someone who would be dedicated to the
opportunity that is being offered to you
so uh please make sure that you are
doing that
and for asiya can postdoc
fellow apply for scholarship so we
typically keep it open
for undergraduate level students but you
can still continue to apply for it in
case
you are accepted you can avail the
scholarship options
so let me also quickly again share with
you the scholarship
link i think i missed out on sharing the
scholarship link with everybody so this
is the scholarship request so please
continue to post it here
let me just share it in the chat okay
so this is the scholarship form once you
go down here
you would be seeing that we clearly
mentioned that
mention a reference from your college or
university administration
with their name email and phone number
so please fill out this form
to receive any kind of communication
from
our end and let me quickly again go back
to our to my part of the presentation
and we are also coming to the end so
if you have any other questions please
continue to post them
so as we discussed today we offer
omix logic programs on these and omix
logic training on these several topics
like transcriptomics is what we talked
about but we also
offer our mixed logic training on
genomics
on introduction to bioinformatics
metagenomics epigenomics as well as
data science
for also i want to answer this that
we do not have any typically fellowship
projects
available so maybe i can go over this in
a minute again
what we do is that we offer a training
where
if you are interested in working on your
own project you come and you join that
training
you train with us for the first period
of say three to four weeks we guide you
through different
sessions courses different resources the
next part is where
you submit your own research project
so that topic is typically not given by
us
you can work on any areas so if you had
to take a look
at the different uh projects that i have
shared earlier you would see that that
ranges from neuroscience from
cancer corporate 19
etc to any other projects that you are
interested in doing so we would
typically ask that with you will have an
orientation session with you as you join
to learn about this and we'll
talk more about that so if you are
interested please
uh let me know you can reach out to me
marketing at pine.bio for these
questions for today's session we do not
offer any certificate if you're
interested
uh you would have to join one of these
programs and we definitely offer
certificate for completing any of the
training programs and they range from a
certificate of excellence that i have
demonstrated earlier
to a certificate of completion depending
on your performance during the session
and of course shashi kant we would be
sending you
the certificate uh sorry the session
recording from today's session
are there any questions please continue
to post them
and i hope that you are going to be
joining us
in our different groups and i've already
demonstrated these different groups to
you
so thank you again
and i have another poll that i am going
to be
launching right here on my screen
so let me just go ahead okay
just let me go back to the whole screen
i'm sorry about this
okay right
so here are a few questions that i would
like to learn but if you are interested
in attending this one month program
if you are you can say yes
and if you are not interested in
attending the program are you interested
in taking the course asynchronously so
asynchronously meets
on your own if you are interested in a
research project on transcriptomics and
if you are interested in additional
mentor support
so thank you again please continue to
answer the polls
and let me go back and
show our zoo some of these
slides on research fellowship right
so that was the question like
regarding research fellowship okay
so uh elia can you confirm if the polls
are in progress
i mean i cannot see the votes
you've got about 60 of the people voted
already
okay thank you so much okay let me go
and find that out okay sorry about that
this
took a while so just to answer that
question i will be after this poll
demonstrating to you again
how to go about the project
and typically we recommend everybody
to first go through a training program
because then it becomes
easier to work on a project once you
have already taken a training in
any of the areas so we continue to give
training in genomics
as i mentioned metagenomics even on
precision oncology we have a session
going
on in precision oncology at the moment
so that program is not open for
registration as we have already advanced
in that program but we continue
to have these programs dedicated
to different topics like you saw that
this transcriptomics program is part of
infectious disease program so it's like
a six month long program that has been
going on
and therefore you are welcome to join
any of these training programs
and then also work on a project now like
if you're interested
in doing a novel project without doing
the training you still can go ahead
only you would be required to give that
additional amount of time
that is required to go forth with this
training
so i'm ending the poll right now
and i'm not sure if anybody can see my
screen
i don't know why my screen is not
visible
i'm sorry about that now we can see
okay perfect
so here as you see is this
different guidelines for presentation
that we have given
and if you notice that different
projects that are here
you would see that these are on
different topics so for example this is
on forward 19
this is on triple negative breast cancer
this is on
glioblastoma stem cells which is on
neuroscience
again different types of projects and
here is also a review so you can see
that these projects have been
recommended by the participants or this
is a
interest area that a participant has on
their own
that you would be able to understand
when you review the
videos here so please feel free to
review the videos again
i'll again post the links and thank you
elia for sharing
all of the links again in the chat box
but as we discussed today
to register for the transcriptomics
program and if you're
interested in learning about rna-seq
this is the
program transcriptomics.omixlogic.com
right so for alzheimer's we have a very
interesting blog so let me also find
that blog link for you
so this may take a while
and if it's not loading maybe uh elia
doctor dr mohit can help me with this
it's just not loading for me right now
so i will not
go over that so
i do not understand uh priyansh the
question
they want you to email them so if you
could just do it okay okay
i got it thank you so much yes so for
every question that was asked what we
would try to do is email all of these
links to you
so that you have the different links you
can study the different links
at your own pace and time will also
share with you
a link for all of our omics logic
programs right now i have a lot of links
opened up so i
guess that everybody would be very
confused so
anytime you want to know which program
is upcoming
you will be able to check out the all
pro comics logic program link
and find the upcoming session so that
could be related to
any of the programs that we have so
thank you all
again for joining today i welcome you to
join
the upcoming sessions and hope that
you'll be able to take part
in the upcoming workshops as well as the
programs that we have
and ask us any questions so that we are
able to help you
work on your own area of research that
you are interested in
and if there are no more questions i
thank you all again for joining
today's session it was great to interact
with everybody here
and i'll see you all in the next session
thank you everybody
you